I want to
reflect with you all on a couple of
verses of the Quran.
When he speaks to a people
that are endeavoring
to do the same thing, they're on the
same path, they're all counted as one.
What each of the individuals of that
party does reflects back on the whole.
For instance,
you find in the Quran, and this this
stretches even across time,
not just in one time, but even across
time.
For instance,
Allah
speaks to
the Jews of Medina. He addresses them in
the Quran in Surah Al-Baqarah.
And you notice something interesting
that throughout this dialogue, Allah
Ta'ala
he is reminding them
of mistakes that were made
by their predecessors.
Mistakes that were made by the people
that were with Musa.
But he speaks to them
in the first person as if they were the
ones that were with Musa.
For instance, Allah
says,
[Silence]
He says, "We saved you
from the clutches of Pharaoh. You all
worshipped the
the calf, the golden calf."
He's speaking to people that came
2,000 plus years after Musa.
So why is it that he is speaking to the
people in the time of the Prophet
Alayhi Wasallam?
However,
he is addressing them
and addressing mistakes that they made
that were made by their predecessors
hundreds and hundreds of years earlier.
What's the reason?
The Prophet
explains this reason.
He says,
[Silence]
He says that
the believers are one single body.
If any one part of that body
is ailing from something,
then the rest of the body suffers from
insomnia
and suffers from fever because of that
one little part that reflects back on
the whole.
And this stretches even across time.
And so we are all treated as one unit.
Some of us make a mistake, it will
reflect back on the rest of us.
Some of us do good If you could please,
I mean
you know, this isn't a play time or a
play area, please.
And
he addresses us
Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
as being
He addresses us
as a whole.
Even if we weren't physically there,
it reflects back on all of us.
When one person makes a mistake, it
reflects back on the whole. When a group
makes a mistake, a minority makes a
mistake, it reflects back on the whole.
We discussed a couple of days ago
the statement of the Prophet
Alayhi Wasallam,
that if the people of Ash-Sham
become corrupt,
then there is no good in all of you, in
all of you.
The people of Ash-Sham, they're the
heartbeats of the larger Muslim Ummah.
It's the pulse.
When we look at the Battle of Uhud,
how many
people were put How many archers were
placed on the archers' mound in the
Battle of Uhud? Who remembers?
About 40. Very good.
Homegrown historian here. We have about
about 40, a few over 40.
How many were in the army that attended
Uhud with the Prophet
Alayhi Wasallam?
Huh?
It was over 1,000,
roughly.
How many is 40 from 1,000?
0.5%.
That's a tiny amount, isn't it? 0.5%.
The battle was lost because of what?
Because of 0.5% disobeyed. And Allah
spoke to the Muslimin and said,
He spoke to the Prophet
and all of the Muslimin,
"And you all disobeyed."
In the Battle of Uhud, how many of them
disobeyed? Not 40, less than 40, because
we have about four to six men that
stayed on that mound. So it was more
that disobeyed from 1,000 men.
Yet that disobedience was counted as
what? The failure of the whole.
In the Battle of Al-Yamamah
with Musaylimah,
when they were in Al-Yamamah and they
were fighting, Khalid ibn al-Walid
radiyallahu anhu was
the
he had taken the position at that
point of general.
They were having a very hard time to
penetrate the ranks of Musaylimah. It
was a very fierce army.
And so the Muhajirin and Ansar, the
companions,
they came to Khalid during the battle
and they demanded
that anyone who is not a companion be
purged from their ranks.
"We want a battalion only being
companions, nobody else. Give them their
own battalion.
We want a battalion that is purely
Muhajirin and Ansar."
Why did they request that? When they did
that, they were able to penetrate the
ranks of Musaylimah and he was
ultimately killed.
Why? Why did the companions do that?
There's a secret here.
Listen to this.
In Surah Al-Anfal,
there are two verses that come back to
back
that tell us
when the Muslim is permitted
to flee in a time of battle.
The first verse tells us,
20 to 200 is how many?
10 per per man.
So Allah is telling them,
"If there's 20 of you and 200 of the
enemy, you're not allowed to turn around
and run. You fight them and you will
win."
Then Allah says in the second verse,
right after it,
Then he tells us,
So now it it was abrogated mansukh, and
the ruling became
it is two men to one.
That is a huge difference. 10 to one,
and then
it was later abrogated as what? Two to
one.
[Silence]
What was this Dha'f?
It's a good question, right?
He said Allah now is relieving you, and
he knows that you have weakness in you.
So, if there is a hundred of you,
then they will be able to beat 200 of
the enemy.
And a thousand of you, they will be able
to beat 2,000 of the enemy. That's a
huge start difference from 20 to 200 and
100 to 1,000.
But, he said, "Allah now has relieved
you all,
and he has recognized that you have
weakness in you."
When were these verses revealed? This is
the question.
That first verse,
one man against 10,
that that that's that's amazing.
One man against 10 men?
I mean, that's a miracle in itself.
This is the quality of the companions
with the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam.
And so,
one to 10,
this was revealed around the time of the
Battle of Uhud of the Battle of Badr,
excuse me.
The Battle of Badr was in which year?
The second year.
When the Battle of Badr happened,
and when
Abu Jahl was killed, and when many of
these sanadid of Quraysh were killed,
and when the muslimeen were were
victorious, what happened in Medina?
Something big happened
to where this verse was abrogated. What
happened?
Huh?
No.
The hypocrites joined.
Abdullah ibn Ubayy ibn Salul and his
group of hypocrites and their tribes,
they decided cuz they were waiting to
see what would happen in Badr. They're
waiting to see which team is winning.
Cuz they join that team. They're like
cockroaches. Whichever team is winning,
that's the one they're going to go with.
And so, when the Battle of Badr
happened, and the muslimeen were
victorious, immediately, what did they
do? They went and pledged allegiance to
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
What happened to the potency of the
Muslim army when the hypocrites joined?
It became diluted.
Correct?
A person may say, "Well, we still have
that same number of good muslimeen and
quality muslimeen." Yes, but they've
been diluted and weakened by
all of the
all of the hypocrites that joined.
That is the da'f that Allah is speaking
about in this verse.
It seems a paradox, doesn't it?
Paradoxical.
Because you would think
that the greater numbers would increase
the responsibility. No.
When their numbers became tripled, their
numbers became tripled when Abdullah ibn
Ubayy ibn Salul joined and the
hypocrites joined and their respective
tribes,
the ranks of the muslimeen tripled.
However, that did what to the Muslim
strength?
It weakened it. It didn't make it
stronger, it made it weaker.
Because it's a chemical.
It's a chemical reaction. The more
you add water to it, what happens to it?
It weakens it. It's no longer as
concentrated.
And that is exactly what Allah is
speaking about here. What's the point of
all this? Why are we discussing this?
The idea
that I can see my brother
disobeying Allah,
living his life in ignorance,
not commanding the good and forbidding
the evil and spreading knowledge,
and insisting that no man is left
behind,
to think that when I go home at night,
or our brothers across the water,
that they are not affected by our
disobedience
is a pipe dream.
They are affected by our disobedience.
When we disobey, it affects the
muslimeen all the way across.
When
I see my brother disobey Allah, and I do
not correct him,
and we do not have people amongst us
that command the good and forbid the
evil and insist on good, what happens to
us? become weakened.
We become divided because the idea is
that a shaytan whispers, "No, well, you
don't want to command the good and
forbid the evil too much." Al amr bil
ma'ruf wal nahy anil munkar. If you do
it too much, you're going to divide the
muslimeen.
Is that what Musa did when they
asked to have an ilah?
When they asked Musa alayhis salaam,
ij'al lana ilahan kamalahum alihah.
Madha qala Musa? Hal qala
ana ya'ni urji'u amrahum ila hin. Al'an
[Arabic recitation]
natfarraq al'an.
Khallina kulluna muttahidin ala hal
kalimatil wahidah.
Ma binna niza'il hada wala nnafir hada.
Wa ba'din in sha Allah bit'allamu.
Hakadha qala Musa alayhis salaam.
Bal qala,
innakum qawmun
tajhalun.
[Arabic recitation]
batilum ma kanu ya'malun.
Qala a ghayrallahi abghikum ilahan wa
huwa faddalakum alal alamin?
Immediately corrected it.
Immediately he corrected it because
this
illusion of a big number, it does not
give us victory. What gives us victory
isn't the strength of our numbers, it is
the quality of our numbers. That's what
gives us victory.
That is what gives us victory.
Wa yawma Hunayn in idh a'jabatkum
kathratukum
falam tughni ankum
min Allahi
shay'a.
And the in the Battle of Hunayn, at
first, they lost the battle. At first,
many of them fled the battlefield.
Companions. What caused them to flee the
battlefield? An attitude that permeated
the Muslim ranks. Qalu, "Lan nughlabal
yawma an qillah."
Kalimatun qaluha.
[Arabic recitation]
W-
They said, "We're not going to be beat
because of a lack of numbers today."
Meaning, our numbers are way too big for
us to be defeated. What happened?
Defeat. Immediately.
Because that is not where victory comes
from. Victory comes from the quality of
those numbers, even if they are few.
And so,
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
tells us, and we will end with this, in
sha Allah.
He says, "La ta'murunna bil ma'ruf
wala tanhawunna anil munkar,
aw layushikanna Allah
an yusallita alaykum adhaban min indih,
thumma latad'unnahu fala yustajabu
lakum."
Nas'al Allah al afiyah.
Hadith fis sunan an Hudhayfah.
The prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said, "You will all command one another
with good and forbid one another evil,
or
a dooming
punishment dangles, looms above you from
Allah,
that once it takes all of you,
you will then pray to him and he will
not answer your prayer." But, there's
good men amongst us. Yes, the good men
amongst you, then why didn't they speak
up?
Why didn't they make a change?
Why weren't
they silent and complicit?
This is the problem.
We have to command the good. We have to
forbid the evil. Or we are all going to
sink on this ship, all of us. There's no
such thing as "My religion and my
relationship with Allah is my personal
thing."
But, then when I go out into society, we
just do whatever we have to do to get
along. That's not how it works. Religion
is inherently divisive.
And we have to make sure that when we
bring a person to Islam, or when we call
a brother to Islam, or when we invite
each other to the sunnah, we do it bil
hikmah wal maw'izah hasanah, and we do
not focus on the minor issues when there
are more major issues to be addressed.
But, we never allow ourselves to see our
brother doing wrong that is
categorically wrong and just ignore it.
That is you shooting yourself in your
own foot. Because al mu'minu mir'atul
mu'min.
In ra'a fihi ayban, aslahahu. Yaqulu
[Arabic recitation]
kama fi musnadil Imam Ahmad. He said,
"The believer is the mirror of his
brother.
If he sees something wrong with him, he
will correct it." You don't look in the
mirror, see something on your face, and
then just go to work and go about your
business. You don't leave until you fix
it, correct?
Your brother, that is your face
he is wearing.
And you will insist that your brother
will do the best he can be. We try to
bring the best out of each other.
And you know what? any disease and
any illness, when you first try to
introduce medicine,
what does the disease do?
It fights back
immediately.
The people that are harmed the most are
the people that command the good and
forbid the evil.
To the point that Imam Ahmad said,
[Silence]
He said a day will come when the
believer amongst the Muslimin will be
a dead carcass that people will
avoid.
Just they used to avoid the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
[Silence]
This is how they were.
And so the believer
Nuh alaihi salaam, people used to hide
from him cuz they don't want to hear
[Arabic recitation]
That is the path of the believer.